es ist der Tag an dem die Welt sich
endgültig verabschiedet von Queen
Elizabeth heute wird sie beerdigt und
sie rennen und sprinten denn es sind die
letzten die es noch in die Warteschlange
schaffen die letzten die die Möglichkeit
bekommen am Sarg der Queen Abschied zu
nehmen hier sehen wir die Leute in der
Schlange die sich persönlich
verabschieden wollen letzte Nacht um 23
Uhr deutscher Zeit wurde die Schlange
dann geschlossen und wärst bis dahin
nicht geschafft hatte der durfte sich
nicht mehr in die kilometerlange
Warteschlange einreihen um Queen
Elizabeth Lebewohl zu sagen bis 36
britischer Zeit durfte heute dann noch
Abschied genommen werden in der
Westminster Hall
und unsere bildreporterin Annika rasch
ist jetzt am Ausgang von Westminster
Hall werden es dann noch alle die
anstehen schaffen den Sarg zu sehen
guten Morgen Lisa ja die die Briten
lieben das curring also das Anstehen und
natürlich ist es Ehrensache dass man
jetzt für seine Queen ansteht ist weil
die längste aller britischen
Warteschlangen und du hattest es eben
schon gesagt gestern abend um 22:40 Uhr
unserer Zeit also 23:40 Uhr eurer Zeit
hat man diese Warteschlange geschlossen
und jetzt wir können einmal hier neben
mich schauen das sind eben jetzt die
letzten die hier aus der Westminster
Hall kommen wir stehen hier direkt am
Ausgang eine halbe Stunde haben die
Menschen jetzt noch Zeit Abschied zu
nehmen die Armbänder die man bekommen
hat sobald man in diese Schlange
gekommen ist werden mittlerweile oder
wurden bis gestern Abend bei ebay
verkauft für bis zu 500 Pfund dann hat
man eben dann diese Schlange verkürzt
weil man einfach gedacht hat die Leute
schaffen es jetzt nicht mehr jetzt haben
wir mit einigen gesprochen die hier
gerade rausgekommen sind und die haben
uns gesagt sie haben nur acht Stunden
angestanden was relativ wenig ist und
man hat ihn wohl gesagt man versucht das
alle die jetzt noch nicht verstehen es
wirklich noch schaffen und ein kleines
seit Info sozusagen noch man darf kein
Essen und kein trinken mit in diese Hall
nehmen die das wird einem vorher
sozusagen abgenommen und das wird dann
eben hier in London den Bedürftigen
gespendet acht Stunden anstehen und das
ganze bei 10 Grad in der Kälte ohne
Essen und Trinken also ein wirklicher
Royal Fans die dort Abschied genommen
haben wenige Stunden sind es noch bis
zur Trauerfeier ist London denn schon
aufgewacht
London ist tatsächlich aufgewacht und so
voll wie es eigentlich normalerweise ist
aber zur Mittagszeit man hat um die
ganze Stadt 21 Kilometer ring of steel
gebaut sozusagen also es sind Straßen
abgesperrt 10.000 Beamte sind hier sind
hier vor Ort es ist jede Kreuzung mit
sehr sehr vielen Beamten teilweise mit
hunderten Beamten besetzt und wir können
hier einmal schwenken und uns das einmal
anschauen ihr seht auf der Kreuzung wie
voll diese Kreuzung schon ist eigentlich
kann da kein weiterer Mensch mehr stehen
viele Menschen wir gucken gerade auf
eine Kreuzung da habe ich mit Menschen
gesprochen die da seit zwei Nächten
Campen zum Beispiel Freundin die alle
Ende 70 sind und sagen das ist der
letzte Dienst die der den wir unserer
Queen erweisen können und man hat hier
tatsächlich jede einzelne Ampel
kontrolliert und darauf untersucht dass
da keine Bomben oder sonstiges versteckt
sind und noch eine Sache die eben
passiert ist und zwar hier hinter mir
wurde eben die
sogar Fett abgeladen das ist praktisch
der alte Wagen der zu über 120 Jahre alt
auf denen am Ende der sagt der Queen aus
der West Hand Münster Hall wir schauen
uns einmal den Weg an rüber zur
Westminster Abbey gefahren wird und zwar
von 98 Matrosen Anleihen gezogen wird
Annika du warst zusammen mit unserer
Kollegin Kira Ortmann schon die letzten
Tage in London unterwegs und ihr habt
geschaut wie sich die Stadt vorbereitet
auf eines der größten Events seit der
Olympischen Spiele die ja vor zehn
Jahren 2012 in London stattgefunden
haben also richtig viel los und wie die
Stadt sich vorbereitet schauen wir uns
jetzt an
London im Ausnahmezustand neben den 2000
geladenen Gästen zu Beerdigung von Queen
Elizabeth II kommen aktuell Touristen
aus der ganzen Welt in die englische
Hauptstadt um der Queen die letzte Ehre
zu erweisen und der Monarchen noch
einmal nahe zu sein die Folge gesperrte
Straßen verengte Fußgängerwege an jeder
Ecke Polizisten oder Ordnungspersonal
mehr als zwei Millionen Menschen werden
zur Trauerfeier der Queen hier in London
erwartet und wir können uns hier einmal
umschauen wie die Kreuzung Investments
ja gerade aussieht tausende Menschen
warten darauf überhaupt über die Straße
gehen zu können der Weg von Westminster
Abbey zum Big Ben dauert bis zu einer
Stunde zu Fuß dieser Weg dauert
normalerweise eigentlich drei bis fünf
Minuten von der einstelle wo es so voll
ist in London zu der anderen wo fast gar
nichts mehr los ist hier ist eine der
Hauptstraßen in Lond Mall die zum
Buckingham Palace für die natürlich
jetzt komplett abgesperrt ist und das
schon seit Tagen und hier warten schon
einige Menschen darauf dass der sagt der
Queen hier ein letztes Mal lang geführt
wird
und die Londoner nehmen die überfüllten
oder auch abgesperrten Straßen sogar
relativ gelassen
wir kommen langsam voran aber es ist
alles sehr organisiert
es ist wirklich eine Ausnahmesituation
also akzeptieren wir das
viele gesperrte Straßen man muss neue
Wege finden und wenn Sie zu Beginn nein
sagen musst du es eben noch ein zweites
Mal probieren
wir haben gerade probiert da vorne
durchzukommen aber es funktioniert nicht
es fühlt sich auch ganz schön eng an da
vorne alles ist sehr ruppig ich wünsche
allen nur viel Glück Gott beschütze den
König
Geduld haben die meisten Londoner die
sich in Westminster und Umgebung
rumtreiben auf jeden Fall mitgebracht zu
Ehren ihre geliebten Königin
man könnte von Chaos sprechen man könnte
mit Chaos rechnen in dieser Situation
ist London aber nicht wenn man so gut
vorbereitet ist und so gut aufgestellt
ist und es eine Selbstverständlichkeit
für viele Briten ist dieses ja sozusagen
dieses nicht vorankommen in Kauf zu
nehmen wir schauen jetzt einmal noch
hier nach rechts das ist praktisch das
Zentrum der Trauerfeier heute und wir
sehen dass dieser Platz jetzt gerade
leer ist weil dieser Platz auch leer
bleibt man wird hier heute alles
zumachen das praktisch man für
Sicherheit sorgen kann und keine
Schaulustigen wirklich nah rankommen und
praktisch nur in den Nebenstraßen
bleiben können
vielen Dank Annika rasch für die ganz
aktuellen Einblicke live aus London von
westminsterhaus
[Musik]